stephen k congratulations you guys have
made it
into the third and final round of this
competition let me say this you fellas
can forge man you guys really brought
your a game
but you're gonna have to step it up
because now we're sending you back to
your home forges to recreate this iconic
weapon from history
the rooster head french pioneer sword
[Music]
gentlemen good luck we'll see you in
four days
we're here in la ranger louisiana and
i'm ready to get going
we're going to try to whack this piece
of metal out and get it
into profile i start off at the tip
because it's probably the most demanding
and i'll work my way back from there
traditionally these blades have a slight
saber type bend in them
so i heat it up and i whack it over the
end of the anvil
i'm very tired but i got the forging of
my blade done
while i'm waiting for it to cool off i'm
just going to go work on my rooster head
combo
i found this chicken head i thought it
would be perfect so i can make the mold
to
cast we bronze i wasn't able to heat
treat
but what i didn't get done on the blade
i got done on my molds
so still feel like i'm on track
so it's the morning of day two and i've
got a lot of work to do today
i have to cut my saw teeth into the back
now i'm ready for the heat treat this is
proving a little more difficult than i
thought it'd be to get an even heat
this plate isn't all the way hard can't
turn in a blade that's half hard
i am screwed so here we go again
i'm gonna set here and re-quench this
and re-straighten this until it's hard
there's some flames that's what we want
to see
i file tested skating like glass
that's a hard blade
i'm starting off the day grinding my
fullers you don't know how that's going
to go
one danger of having a double-sided
puller is you can grind
straight through your blade and so i
just kind of go down the blade and check
and make sure i'm not doing that
i got to sharpen the saw back too i
don't know what they're going to test
this thing on hopefully it'll
hog away some stuff now that i'm done
with that
it is time to heat treat
it's hard today i'm gonna try to conquer
casting this is my absolute first time
doing
any casting so hopefully i can get it
figured out
i want to pass three pieces there's the
guard piece
handle and then there's the rooster
headed pommel my first
casting is just a piece of bronze that's
gonna be
the guard with the upswept quillians all
right
that's way more than enough for a guard
i have the guard cast which i'm pretty
happy about i have the handle
cast then i got this rooster i can see
an
eye i can see the detailed feathers on
this side freaking sweet
this is a lot denser and heavier than i
thought which i'm happy about because my
blade is super forward heavy and
i want that balance point to just get
farther back on the blade
going into day four i have the three
pieces of my handle so
my day tomorrow is going to be tedious
finish work
the morning of day four and today it's
just putting it all together
by casting my rooster head and my guard
and if i may say
this is one bomb chicken head look at
that bad boy
handle comes next
that's about it everything's looking
pretty good
i got it all right blade spins
your blades look lovely but are they
deadly
i'm gonna take your weapons deliver some
lethal cuts and slashes on this
goat carcass it's time to find out
they're ready for a cockfight
or they going to play chicken steve in
the uppers you ready for this let's do
[Music]
it
[Music]
all right stevens talking about your
sword here it's
beautiful looking but it's a heavy sword
but that
lends itself to deliver very deep cuts
with every swing
and more importantly it will kill
all right kate your turn so you ready
yes sir
[Music]
all right kids talk about your sword
here your handle construction
fits perfectly in my hand now your edge
is pristine
no glints no rollings whatsoever and
most importantly
it'll kill all right gentlemen welcome
to the strength test
the log chop now to test the strength
and overall durability of your blades
i'll be chopping on this log
all right steven you're up first are you
ready for this let's do it
right first off stephen nice job on the
castings they're nicely done
your handle is about an inch too long it
allows my hand to
travel around a lot your blade took no
damage whatsoever
good job thanks all right kade you're up
next you ready
yes sir
[Music]
all right cade your blade good condition
no rolls no chips still sharp as it was
when i started good job
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the scarecrow
saw and slice test the sawbacks on your
weapon i'll be sewing to the wooden
dowels then i'll test the edge by
cutting the watermelon
and the sugarcane bundle steven you're
up first you ready
let's do it
[Music]
all right steven let's talk about your
saw back here
once it gets started it starts to saw it
works it's a functional saw back in
there
you're able to dig into the dowel your
edge is sharp
no issues cutting on the watermelon and
the weight alone is gonna just
chop that whole thing off overall sir
it'll cut
thank you all right kate your turn you
ready
yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
all right kade saw back these teeth
are sharp even at the start it already
digs in a couple of slices in there it's
already
digging right into the wooden double
your edge
no issues whatsoever it cuts to the
watermelon and
cuts the rest of the sugar king bundles
overall sir
it'll tap thank you all right
bladesmiths the weapons tests are
complete and the judges literally had to
weigh the details
the new fortune fire champion is
okay congratulations you are the foreign
fire champion
steven your blade is two pounds heavier
than cade's blade
making it less wieldy additionally your
handle is a little bit
out of proportion with the blade and
it's for that reason that you cannot be
the forge of fire champion
come on forward my friend even though i
feel
somewhat defeated right now i'm still
proud of what i've done and i'm proud of
what i turned in
the beast man well nothing thank you
you're a great competitor thank you
steven
caskey i'm not gonna say i'm gonna go
home and start making swords um but i
did really enjoy the whole
process and it also taught me what i
could do in a short amount of time not
that it's my best work
but i'm proud of myself for not giving
up there
okay congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
right now
cock-a-doodle-doo
[Laughter]
good job my friend you made a fine
rooster headed french pioneer sword come
on forward and shake our hand
i am super psyched right now i am so
proud
of myself and i thank god that i had
this opportunity
i got to keep working hard and keep on
trying to climb that ladder you know
10 grand is college funds
you